verheerende waldbrände wie er hinter uns
wir müssen uns daran gewöhnen dass diese
nachricht aus deutschland kommt aus
unserem wald das ganze wochenende
diese bilder waldbrände auf einer fläche
so groß wie ja ungefähr 700
fußballfelder südlich von berlin
treuenbrietzen ein kleiner ort im wald
liegt noch ganz viel munition da kann
die feuerwehr also ganz schwer nur
löschen und auch in beelitz das kennen
sie vielleicht das ist diese spargel
region auch dort brennt es genauso da
brennt der wald die luftwaffe hilft da
inzwischen mit hubschraubern zum löschen
eigene löschflugzeuge wie man das aus
südeuropa kennt die gibt es in
deutschland nicht räumpanzer kommen
mittlerweile zum einsatz und auch
wasserwerfer der polizei doch es brennt
immer noch seit tagen ein bisschen
regnet überhaupt nichts geändert an
dieser lage die rauchschwaden dieser
brände die kann man von berlin aus sehen
ja der brandgeruch den riecht man je
nach wind sogar in dresden und diese
brände die sind längst eine gefahr für
die menschen die in der nähe dieser
feuer leben in brandenburg in den
dörfern schauen sie raus aus den häusern
evakuierungen in den vergangenen stunden
die menschen müssen alles hinter sich
lassen in der hoffnung dass sich die
flammende ihre häuser nicht holen raus
aus den dörfern und rein dann in
notunterkünfte solange bis endlich die
verheerenden brände unter kontrolle sind
jetzt gehen wir zu diesen waldbränden
das ist immer noch ein wort das man eher
mit kalifornien mit süd europa verbindet
waldbrände sind aber hier sind in
brandenburg in deutschland ab zu unserer
reporterin bild reportern klara marie
becker dort vor ort und der blick zuerst
richtung himmel klar ist dass die
hoffnung kann der regen diese
verheerenden waldbrände heute in den
nächsten stunden löschen
ja keine die ganze nacht hat es hier
schon geregnet auch zu den frühen
morgenstunden es hat es vor einer stunde
ungefähr aufgehört zu regnen aber die
feuerwehr uns gesagt das ist uns eine
riesig große hilfe sie hoffen auf noch
mehr regen heute im laufe des tages denn
sie können eben teilweise in die wälder
in denen es brennt nicht reinfahren mit
ihren fahrzeugen aufgrund der
munitionsreste die sich in diesen
wäldern befinden das wäre zu gefährlich
für die feuerwehr deswegen können sie
nur von der straße aus oder eben aus der
luft löschen und da hilft es natürlich
extrem wenn es dann hier weiter regnet
um gegen diese flammen anzukämpfen
um diese brände dann auch wieder unter
kontrolle zu bringen es ist ja die
nachricht clara maria oft die so viele
menschen jetzt gerade hoffen menschen
die ihr haus verlassen mussten wie geht
es den menschen wie viele sind derzeit
noch nicht in ihre häuser zurückgekehrt
und müssen ausharren und darauf warten
wie sich das feuer weiter ausbreitet
oder eben nicht
behle zwar hier der erste ort der
gestern teilweise evakuiert werden
musste es mussten mehrere hundert
menschen aus bestimmten teilen von
beelitz eben aus ihren häusern raus und
in dieser notunterkünfte dann vor etwa
einer stunde kam jetzt die erleichternde
nachricht für die menschen hier in
beelitz das betrifft wirklich nur
beelitz dass sie jetzt wieder in ihrer
häuser zurückkehren dürfen also die
evakuierung ist aufgehoben durch den
bürgermeister vor einer stunde offiziell
auf der internetseite der stadt beelitz
das ist natürlich eine enorme
erleichterung für die menschen aber es
wurde auch gewarnt weiterhin die türen
zuzulassen weiterhin die fenster
zuzulassen vorsichtig zu sein denn diese
brände sind eben noch nicht vollständig
unter kontrolle gebracht es kann immer
wieder zur auch er kommen der sich der
hier durch das dorf getragen wird und ja
diesen tagen ist natürlich nach wie vor
nicht zu 100 prozent sicher gesehen
werden du sprichst klara marie die
bilder von den hubschraubern wieder im
einsatz waren die letzten 50 stunden gab
teilweise skurrile szenen da gestern an
den badeseen drumherum voll mit den
badenden und mittendrin die hubschrauber
die wir bisher sehen können dann
eimerweise tonnenweise das wasser hoch
geholt haben um dann zu löschen im wald
schilder uns noch mal deine eindrücke
wie mit welchen mitteln wird dort vor
ort gegen die brände gekämpft
ja die wasserversorgung ist wirklich ein
problem das hat uns auch der
einsatzleiter der feuerwehr hier vor ort
gesagt also sie haben einfach enorme
probleme die löschfahrzeuge weiterhin
mit wasser zu befüllen deswegen musste
man eben teilweise auch auf umliegende
sehen zu greifen nicht nur die die
nicht nur die feuerwehrautos sondern
eben auch die luftwaffe musste zu diesen
mitteln greifen aber es sind wirklich
enorm viele einsatzkräfte auch noch
heute morgen hier vor ort gewesen die
polizei ist da mit wasserwerfern die
feuerwehr aus den umliegenden orten und
aus berlin ist hier das technische
hilfswerk ist hier und eben die
luftwaffe aber auch noch im einsatz die
ganze nacht also da wurden wirklich alle
kräfte mobilisiert um diese brände so
schnell wie möglich oder so gut wie
möglich unter kontrolle zu bringen was
weiß man klarer marie zu diesem
zeitpunkt über eine mögliche
brandursache
auch darüber wird mit der feuerwehr
gesprochen
man kann es noch nicht genau sagen es
gibt mehrere möglichkeiten das könnte
sein dass eben die munitionsreste die in
den wäldern noch liegen dass die eine
ursache für den brand sind denn immer
wenn er also in dem moment in dem es so
heiß ist jetzt in den letzten tagen und
so trocken ist und es eben dann zu
bränden kommt und diese munitionsreste
teilweise auch noch explodieren können
hat uns ein hat uns der einsatzleiter
erzählt wird das feuer natürlich weiter
getragen und entfacht sie rechnen aber
auch damit also ist es auch eine
möglichkeit das eben brandstiftungen
hier in diesem gebiet erfolgt ist das
auch schon vor jahren passiert es gibt
teilweise videomaterial aus den letzten
jahren in denen diese brandstiftungen
erfolgt sind und natürlich ist es auch
dieses jahr wieder eine möglichkeit dass
da einfach menschen in den wäldern
gekokelt haben zigarettenstummel liegen
gelassen haben dinge angezündet haben
und das ist natürlich in bei 37 grad und
einer trockenen hitze wie wir die
letzten tage hatten das bonner breitet
sich so ein feuer innerhalb von wenigen
stunden extrem aus und kann dann eben
nicht mehr unter kontrolle gebracht
werden also der einsatzzeit hat uns
gesagt diese brände dass die so
stattfinden egal ob durch brandstiftung
oder eben weil es zu heiß ist das ist
auch völlig normal
aber normalerweise könnte man diese
brände innerhalb kürzester zeit unter
kontrolle bringen und wir hören jetzt
auch direkt nochmal rein was der
einsatzleiter uns erzählt hat
grosse probleme mit ihrer versorgung die
wahrheit
kennt wen oder durch wasser im name
stellen sofort alle die über lange
wegstrecken hier stellte die
wasserversorgung
wir können in die wälder großen weil
munition verdachtsfläche hier noch vor
ort sind denn da drückt ihr dampf drin
er selber runter ist die richtige wahl
sitze vorne
die munition explodiert ansonsten sind
wir hier so weit jetzt im grünen bereich
sagt er jetzt auch wegen hat das
erhoffen sich weiterhin hat mir dann
auch langsam kräfte los versichert dass
also die einschätzung aktuell des
wichtigsten mannes dort vor ort
derjenige der diesen waldbrand
löscheinsatz dort im moment leite danke
dir für die information vor ort lara
marie becker dort ins brandenburgische
in die region um beelitz ja der blick
nach oben sie haben gerade gesehen in
den himmel das ist die hoffnung der
regen reicht das um diese großen
waldbrände zu löschen unsere reporter
und reporterinnen die berichten den
ganzen tag weiter aus diesem waldrand
band gebiet verzeihung und nach
inzwischen mehr als 50 stunden
verheerende brände
großbrand gerät außer kontrolle mehr als
200 hektar wald stehen in flammen über
600 menschen mussten evakuiert werden
1000 einsatzkräfte der feuerwehr aus
zwei bundesländern bekämpfen die flammen
mehrere hubschrauber der bundeswehr sind
im einsatz
samstagmorgen in treuenbrietzen noch
immer kann die feuerwehr den schweren
brand der bereits am freitag
ausgebrochen ist nicht vollständig
löschen doch zu diesem zeitpunkt ist die
lage noch entspannt
ja wir hatten mal ein treffen einen
waldbrand zucker mit einer aussendung
von anderthalb hektar der sich im
verlauf der löscharbeiten auf
zweieinhalb hektar ausgebreitet hat die
lage ist unter kontrolle
der rand ist abgelöscht führen jetzt die
nachwuchsarbeit mit netz wasser durch
haben ungefähr zehn tanklöschfahrzeuge
meinert schnell scheinen feuerwehr und
anwohner den brand zunächst unter
kontrolle zu bekommen
zum glück hat das feuer die baumkronen
noch nicht erreicht die feuerwehr gibt
zunächst entwarnung
also ich habe sie schon wahnsinn zu
angst weil wir hatten glück mit dem wind
der wind bisschen gedreht hatte wenn wir
hier im dorf praktisch auch abgebrannt
doch dann passiert was nicht passieren
sollte am nachmittag frischt der wind
auf
entfacht das feuer erneut und treibt es
sogar auf erste dörfer zu
acht relativ konsolidierten phase am
roten vormittag an der jetzt seit dem
nachmittag durch den auf
oder den wind und die stärkeren wind hat
das problem dass für eine weitere
ausbreitung des feuers haben weitere
vier bis fünf hektar und das setzt uns
jetzt natürlich noch mal unter druck
weitere mittel einzusetzen die feuerwehr
setzt schweres gerät ein auch ein lösch
hubschrauber des bundesgrenzschutzes ist
mittlerweile im einsatz doch die lage
verschärft sich weiter die behörden
beschließen erste orte zu evakuieren
etwa 20 menschen müssen innerhalb einer
halben stunde ihre häuser verlassen
ja wir werden jetzt noch einmal
aufrüsten wer also einmal kräfte
alarmieren weitere kräfte zu führen
damit wir auch eine personelle ablösung
schaffen und natürlich auch der
versorgung dass der weiterhin und
kontinuierlich wasser heran gekommen das
ist natürlich auch in dieser zeit
die ganze nacht über versucht die
feuerwehr den brand unter kontrolle zu
bringen doch die situation scheint
aussichtslos am abend stehen bereits
über 100 hektar wald in brand und auch
der sonntag morgen bringt keine
entlastung der wind frischt weiter auf
die feuerwehr meldet die kontrolle über
den brand verloren zu haben
mittlerweile sind mehrere hubschrauber
in der luft und fast 1000 rettungskräfte
im einsatz
die mittag entscheiden die behörden zwei
weitere ortschaften zu evakuieren es ist
gar nichts mehr relax also wir haben als
frohnsdorf inzwischen evakuiert
und auch klausdorf weil wir jetzt noch
ein brand haben oder mehrere brände über
der b 102 der wind hat wirklich uns hier
nicht gerade in die hände gespielt also
dadurch hat sich das feuer immer ins
ausgebreitet auf 10 zwischen 200 hektar
[Musik]
am nachmittag dann die meldung dass zwei
weitere brände in der gegend
ausgebrochen sind nahe bei beelitz
brennen bereits mehrere hektar wald aus
der ganzen region werden feuerwehr
kräfte zusammengezogen
wir werden jetzt verlegen in die
landkreis potsdam mittelmark um dort bei
dem brand ereignis zu unterstützen die
kamera den kameraden zu helfen die sache
scheint dort aus ein jahr zu lassen
am späten nachmittag kann auch der
brandenburgische ministerpräsident sieht
man wollte keine entwarnung geben
die situation ist sehr dynamisch und sie
ist sehr bedrohlich und weil sie eine
große dynamik hat wie auch jetzt gerade
wieder eine windböe über uns zu spüren
ist ist durch diese durch diesen böigen
wind durch die ständigen
richtungswechseln des windes ist der
brand unberechenbar in teil noch außer
kontrolle geraten in den letzten stunden
das sind evakuierungen notwendig
geworden 600 menschen wurden bereits
evakuiert und wir können nicht
ausschließen dass weitere menschen
evakuiert werden müssen stand
sonntagabend mittlerweile musste auch
die einsatzleitung ihr lagezentrum
räumen der erhoffte regen blieb bis
jetzt aus